[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
that's roughly the trump legal team's
record in court getting smacked
down by judge after judge in state after
state
because they've pushed ludicrous
accusations without
actual evidence the president's legal
team has not been able to produce any
evidence
of systemic fraud while the president
without any evidence tries to peddle his
own alternative
i want to be very very clear there's
absolutely
no evidence at least none we've seen
of any widespread voter fraud that the
president
and his team are alleging no credible
examples
no credible incidences and now trump
campaign officials without any evidence
to back up their claims
say the new law is right for voter fraud
and they're suing nevada now for
expanding this mail-in voting in the
middle of a public health crisis
in nevada the trump campaign claims
without any evidence
that thousands of people improperly cast
their mail-in ballots
and that that's the actual registered
address yeah we have hundreds
they voted for map yeah
wow
this is definitely going to take a while
subject for today
[Music]
delicious sip steady so let's just say
my half
asian lawyer bill richmond is here with
me by the way people have thought you
disappeared but it's because
we can't talk about it working we're
working working and he makes his fingers
like this which means you know he's
serious and they're stubby
um quarter black garrett is here good
morning i'm sorry for the lack of
acceptance uh gerald
a is here we have a lot to get to some
updates on uh swalwell i was
sad that you weren't here yesterday but
um and by the way everyone watching
the best thing you can do for this right
now just hit like while we're live and
if you're watching the archive
just comment comment on the video that
helps us cut through the youtube
algorithms
i don't know if this will still be up
because it could be considered
against youtube's uh guidelines so we
wanted to have someone authoritative
i know it's not ap but we actually have
here with us uh for an exclusive uh the
attorney general
of texas uh mr uh ken paxton how are you
sir thank you for being here
hey i'm doing great it's been kind of a
slow morning for me but for sure
yeah you're moseying you're doing it at
texas pace by the way do you prefer
um attorney uh mr uh mr paxton
attorney or just general just call me
ken
well come on now i appreciate it you
know
it sounds weird the title is general
paxton that's
that's what the title is the title is
general pax and now to be clear
because a lot of people will say oh hold
on when you need authoritative sources
uh you're a real attorney general right
not a patsy for the higher-ups
that's true i'm a realtor elected by the
people of texas
okay good i want to make sure so youtube
please don't remove him yet
um real really quickly because i know
you're busy you're about to walk over to
the oval office
right after this uh spot and i
appreciate you making the time treat
me like many people in our audience
because i'm sure you know this has
gotten convoluted with different suits
some are brought by the trump team some
are brought by other
lawyers and some have been brought now
in this case by an ag like yourself
what is the suit from texas who are you
guys suing
and uh just in a summary what is the
basis of the suit
okay the first thing i have to say is my
daughter is having a baby today and
my son-in-law said i love this guy can
you get me one of those mugs autographed
by him and i said
i'll do my best well i tell you what i
can't because we're we're rough on
budget and i don't know him
[Laughter]
but uh i would okay well listen i can't
love's a strong word
um no i will get him not only will i get
him a mug i'll get him a whole gift
package we have some new hoodies
and i really appreciate that and we'll
talk after after you deal with some more
important
pressing matters but um recap for people
who don't know
this suit that you have brought against
the state of michigan
georgia wisconsin pennsylvania tell them
what it is what the basis is
so we simply are saying that these
states
ignored the constitution they ignored
their own state laws
and throughout these states local
elected officials
and judges changed the law and made
their
elections not follow state law which
under the constitution they're not
supposed to do they're supposed those
elections are governed by state law by
state legislators and when they start
mucking around with
state law individual counties having
different election laws than other
counties
it creates credibility problems and it's
unconstitutional and it affects my
voters because we did it the right way
we fought off all these lawsuits we
followed state law
and our our elections are credible and
theirs are not and that
this franchise is my voters and the
voters of the rest of the country
absolutely and not only that but texas
was one of the states that rejected
using dominion software
correct and we rejected three we've
rejected it three times
uh and we've also we had 12 lawsuits in
federal court state court
all over the state of texas fifth
circuit texas supreme court
challenging our laws on mail-in ballots
shelling our laws on signature
verification
we were successful in every single one
of them 12 lawsuits and had we not
we would have been in the same situation
as georgia and michigan
and wisconsin and pennsylvania he
rejected it three times so like a voter
fraud rejection
hat trick which by the way i apologize
my half asian lawyer is here he's
breathing like a bulldog let's turn down
his microphone
he's bringing he's
[Applause]
now i want to go back to the
constitutionality here in in a second
but before that you know there's there's
been a lot of rumors circulating and
unfortunately some disinformation
has taken place on the right as well as
the left now 17 states have joined in
as friends of the court right amiki is
the term but that doesn't mean that
they've officially signed on
and and you said that this morning you
can announce right here right now which
states
thus far have officially signed on to
this suit
with you in texas so we have
actually now 18 states arizona is now
part of that amicus
process okay um i don't the other states
that
we are talking to about intervening have
not actually filed so i cannot
say who they are but there are several
states that are
likely to intervene in our case sometime
today sometime today okay you can't give
us a hint
like i don't know if they have something
like i don't know they might be they
might have something to do with but
eyes that are bucked well because you
never know what's going to happen until
they file so until they file
it they're not in so i know the
president tried to intervene
so it's a big deal and this is a big
case right and i had heard listen not
from you i want to be clear about that
but from some inside sources
they expect a minimum of four and a
possibility
of 10. does that sound about right yeah
that that sounds about right um i and i
like i said it
it could happen or not happen i'm not in
control of other states decisions about
whether to intervene i am only in
control of what texas does
we obviously file a lawsuit right uh but
these 17 other states are 18 sorry that
have joined in
so what does that mean for people who
don't understand because some people
think that means that they've officially
joined in on the suit and donald trump
has by the way the president he's talked
about intervening
but what does it mean when they're just
friends of the court we're talking about
that amicus
so intervening you're actually a party
you're standing alongside of us saying
hey this was a wrong
done to our citizens in our state and
amicus is a friend of the court brief
providing guidance to the court on
issues that those states think are
relevant will be relevant to the court
and my understanding is that amicus will
be favorable to us
obviously but it's not like intervening
intervening is like i'm part of this
fight i'm getting in
totally getting in whereas amicus i mean
very helpful and i'm not
we we do a lot of amicus briefs
ourselves because sometimes we can't
intervene
and or it's not strategic to intervene
they're it's not quite the same but it's
certainly useful
well yeah and i understand but how could
it not be strategic for them to
intervene i guess
what should be the tipping point for
someone who's saying well i support it
i'm a friend of the court versus
you know really having skin in the game
because a lot of americans out there
feel like you know they've been gas-lit
they're taking crazy pills
you obviously have the brass pair to
step up americans want to see other
states officially you know sign on that
dotted line
hey we hear you no i'm with you i'd love
to have them i'd take
you know all 18 states intervening if
they wanted to go with us
we want them in we'll take them we're
encouraging them to join us
and to stand on the front lines with us
and when we're
in front of the us supreme court be
there be their present
be a party and and be part of the fight
right and we'll know by the end of the
day that's probably a big part of your
conversation
who is joining in uh officially i i wish
you could tell me
at least even like one or two you know i
mean please
can you also just you know have some
kind of complaint can you put it in
there i know like with a bill in an ear
mark something with john kasich
just say like and by the way he pisses
the rest of the country off is can there
be a
legal filing i don't know if he's going
to be a part of this one
maybe tomorrow just follow that one
tomorrow well just double dog darum to
lick a a poll in the middle of december
and that would that would be good enough
for me
um let me ask you recently filed brief
um you
called uh or sorry called this lawsuit a
mockery
of federalism and separation of powers
right this is the arguments that they're
using
um and they've suggested that it's not
under the supreme court's constitutional
purview
uh to serve as a trial court for the
presidential election dispute so
you know seeing what we've seen before
where a lot of these suits have just
been tossed
right and that's been parroted by the
media where they say oh 40 of donald
trump suits have been tossed
we know those aren't necessarily donald
trump suits these are suits brought on
by many
different people why do you think this
or why is this suit why should americans
understand that this is different that
as donald trump has said the president
this is
the big one so this is different because
it's being brought by state so we have
no other recourse other than to go to
the u.s supreme court all these other
cases at least
whether they were tossed or not at least
you can say they had a chance to be
heard somewhere
we have nowhere else to go i feel like
we've had a harm to my citizens
that their vote their they've been
disenfranchised by these other states in
a
federal national election and so if if
the court
doesn't grant us the ability to make the
argument
we have nowhere to go and we're just
being told
you're not only you're being tossed but
you don't even get to make the argument
you don't even get to be hurt
right and that's the difference because
you know i was watching cnn uh
supr scotus was trending you know on
social media and i thought oh this must
be because of uh general pax didn't suit
and instead it was about
the supreme court you know kicking it
back down to the lower pennsylvania
court that other case that happened on
the same day
and i think people understand that
listen that's something that's happening
within a state it kind of came down to a
deadline issue
but that's very different compared to a
suit between states
necessarily the supreme court has to
intervene because he can't just say well
let the state of
let the supreme court of texas or
pennsylvania figure it out
that's a that's a very stark contrast
that i think
hasn't been uh really nailed into
americans heads yet i don't think they
fully grasp the consequences
no it it's it's it's so important
because i think there are some who think
that the supreme court has to hear our
case i mean there are some on the court
who i think
believe that when the constitution was
written
that states had nowhere to go because if
they can't be heard their only other
opportunity was to go fight each other
right that's why
they have to have a place if you don't
want a war or some other type of action
you have to have a place to go redress
your harm so there are some of the court
who believe that they are required to
hear hear that
unfortunately the majority opinion on
this has been they it's up to them they
can
decide for whatever reason yes or no
they don't have to even have a reason
they can just say no
and unfortunately that's that is the
current i think majority opinion
i'm just hoping in this case they'll see
it as as important enough to hear it
um what i guess you know we've seen
uh these voter rolls uh as it relates to
these issues you know voter uh
irregularities sir on youtube we can't
say voter fraud but
irregularities um people have brought
forward videotape hundreds of affidavits
and so many cases have just been tossed
right tossed what does it take i mean
the evidence hasn't even been examined
in some of these other cases
how do you i guess how do you remain
hopeful that at least
what you're bringing forward and the
evidence is seeing
because we've seen judges say don't want
to see it
so you know we reference some of the
evidence that we have but our case is
fundamentally not even built on that
because
i've watched what's happened and you
know frankly i'm disappointed that it
hasn't gotten a more thorough review
by our judiciary for whatever reason
our case doesn't rest on how valid the
fraud is or not
not we are resting completely on the
constitution that we
know for a fact that these legislatures
had passed laws that were not followed
by local officials
and that there are equal protection
issues about different voters being
treated differently that there are
ballot fraud issues that were not
addressed like no signature verification
you've got drop boxes being dropped in
georgia that are just dropped off and
people can throw their ballots in there
i mean those are in violation of state
law that's a fact
right so we're not we're not basing it
on anything that we have to go prove
as it relates to fraud we're basing it
on what we know happened
as a fact and we're asking the court to
say hey look this is wrong
it needs to be addressed and it
negatively affects you know members of
other states listen as someone who's
sort of more of a libertarian
conservative right we talk about
federalism on this show
i understand states having the ability
to govern themselves
but this is a question that i have and
maybe you might be able to help clarify
because i could be wrong
we do have a baseline minimum you know
of laws meaning okay
you can't kill you can't steal we do
have a baseline minimum for example
nationally
what an adult is for enlistment now
states can change
where you can drink right but why don't
we have it seems like we have a baseline
nationally when elections need to take
place right election day
but how is it how do we juxtapose this
with a constitution where you have some
states where you require a valid address
and some state laws don't um it seems
like there should be some kind of
standardization just to set a baseline
that we know
legal american citizens are are voting
and am i off base there well in
the way that it was set up was that the
states could determine some of these
rules as a related
election so for instance i think nevada
legislature actually went back and
changed their
laws as a related because of covid and
made it very easy to vote by mail and
very
i mean so we do have states where the
legislature set it up so it's it's
it creates some of these issues that
we're talking about and that may be
a national debate that we need to be
having at the federal level to say hey
we need to fix this across the nation
because
we can't trust these elections if the
legislature goes and changes these rules
it makes it really easy for people to
have fraudulent ballots right we are not
going to be able to trust our elections
so i think you're bringing up a really
good
point that needs to be addressed
nationally yeah
very well i appreciate and i know you're
busy i have a couple more questions for
you real quick
i will go to you but one second um and
the reason i bring that up is because we
are doing a show next thursday
right where we are going to be driving
across nevada in an rv
so we have some brilliant researchers
who work here and we have between 30 or
40 or 50 addresses
we'll hit as many as we can live
streaming uncut for four to six hours
addresses that we know don't exist or
invalid addresses
empty lots we will show people because
they hear the numbers and they go
okay a few thousand here but a lot of
people don't believe it the reason we
had to do it in nevada
is because in michigan it's okay for
someone to register an empty lot
and that really struck us as as odd and
it was something that actually narrowed
down the states where we had to say
actually
it's not lawful for you to vote from a
place that doesn't exist but in some
states it is
my uh half asian lawyer here bill
richmond did have a question for you
he's far smarter than i am and i
appreciate your time go ahead uh
uh mr uh kraken
uh general baxter one of the interesting
things i thought stood out from the
filing you made with the supreme court
uh was the phrase an unconstitutional
relation
relaxation of ballot integrity
protections
and to me that's that said it all right
it's saying there are laws in place
there are rules in place and the states
are not following them
we all agree about what they did now
it's just a matter of determining was it
constitutional or unconstitutional
for our audience members across the
country and in these states that are
only amiki or haven't even jumped in
to file an amicus brief on this
particular issue
why should they be interested in making
sure that their voice is heard and that
their attorney generals are actually
joining in to combat
the unconstitutional relaxation of
ballot integrity protections
that's a great question i it it was a
little bit of a boring one i'll be
honest but a little wonkish but go ahead
it was a little long i'll take a little
long
are you sure about those five minutes
all right here we go why should people
why should citizens want their ag's to
join the fight
because i think that they are being
disenfranchised uh
if if your state followed state law
and and produced election results that
were based on state law as required by
the u.s constitution
and other states said we're not going to
follow those constitutional requirements
we're not going to follow our state law
and as a result
we don't really know we can't verify
whether any of these 2.5 million ballots
and
mailing ballots in pennsylvania are real
well
that's a problem for my state because my
state is following the law
and now we've got all these states we
don't know what the real result is and
it affects the outcome of election
and that affects my state yeah it
affects a federal election you know
states changing laws that ultimately
affect
a federal election um three quick
questions for you before you go and i
know you're busy and uh tell the
president i say hi though i don't think
he'll care
um if at three o'clock somebody will
he might he may be like that guy he
wears pajamas
no um at 3 p.m right and we'll know
today
people watching the states that
officially join in but let's say the
supreme court declines to hear your case
what are your next steps you know that's
that we have nowhere to go
i mean okay that's our only place to
file our case we don't have another
filing place we can't go to district
court that's why i am saying
this really matters for the supreme
court to give us a chance to at least
present our side right that's all we're
asking and
another question is there anything that
the american people you know we have
hundreds of thousand people watching
right now right now this second there'll
be millions of people is there anything
they can do
to help yes i think encourage your
attorney general to
intervene i mean or participate in this
process
is our last chance and it may be our
last chance forever
because if this gets set this way
i mean we may never have elections again
that we can count on this is setting the
future
of our country and how elections are
going to be done
right here's my final question and i i
don't mean for it to be a hardball
question but i will say this the sort of
feeling from a lot of americans with you
know donald trump in office and
republicans in control
uh of a lot of areas of government not a
lot has been done you know i go for
example
it required liberals in new york to file
suit
on the grounds of you know 230 or
monopolies with uh with big tech
um when do you think
all republicans are going to or can we
hope for other republicans to grow a
backbone like you seem to be general
paxton i'm just going to tell you we're
really disappointed i'm glad to see you
doing this but we're really disappointed
with the people we've put in office
well you know i understand that i have
my own disappointments by the way on
that facebook complaint we're on that
complaint
yes and you will see more from us
on on different issues coming very soon
so
um no i i get it i i find
it's shocking that you know there's
there were so few people interested
initially and being a part of this i'm
grateful that
you know this this case has created
enough interest that now we've got
people focused on it um i think there's
good reason to have some disappointment
in what republicans have done
and i'm hopeful that this will galvanize
us
to realize that we could lose
our democracy in the way that the
founders set it up and that this really
is like crunch time it's it's
it's a threshold issue issue of of
survival of our
of our democracy yeah i agree with you
and uh there we hear it for american
people to uh petition your ag's
tell them to grow a pair uh and please
let us know i know you're busy and you
have to go we'll be looking for the
official announcement here later today
if there's anything we can do don't
hesitate to reach out uh
and uh please uh be safe today and and
give him hell uh mr paxton
hey i appreciate you having me on and uh
your uh represent
uh reputation precedes you from my own
family members so
um thanks for having me on we're excited
well sounds to me like you need better
family members but thank you mr paxton
i appreciate it give him hell uh that
was very yeah
that was lovely to have him on yeah so
early i i loved
i loved hearing that because he made
that same point that we've been talking
about you can't just break your own laws
with elections
and disenfranchise every other state you
just can't do it right so if the supreme
court does not give him an opportunity
like he
said i i i see very difficult times
ahead
trying to get somebody to listen to what
you're saying if you're in a state that
gets disenfranchised in the future yeah
and i had other things that i wanted to
ask them about i mean they've had
they've had 12 suits in texas on
election fraud that they've won
correct for people to understand this
these things happen within the states um
if the consequences if they had lost
even one of those
could be monumental right every single
one of those was an opportunity that
would have been a monumental failure but
they didn't they pushed forward they did
it the right way
and really what they're saying is and
and i would encourage people to read the
actual complaint that we encourage you
to bring the microphone a little bit
closer no
it's okay because earlier you were
wheezing into it like a pug
i am a pug okay whoa but
here's breaking the puck what audio wave
just really liked me now yeah so here's
the thing is when you
actually read it like that phrase for
example was just incredible where you
know
the unconstitutional relaxation of
ballot integrity protections
i feel like i'm in the locker room high
school
except it was a penis that's so good
every time i run into gerald he's that's
what he tries to do
so so so when you listen to that go read
that and compare that to some of the
other lawsuits that were filed and the
way that it says
is look at the facts we know how you
were running it
in these states we know how you were
running it in the
tfc center tcf center in detroit we know
how you're running into georgia we know
how you're running in pennsylvania
we're not saying you should have done
something like you should have changed
the laws we're saying
you didn't follow your own laws right
right and that calls in questions so
now that that last question i was asking
about why should other people care
it's because if these states are allowed
to do
whatever they want with regards to
ballot integrity protections
yeah that means your vote is reduced
in statute i tell you though yeah we got
an instant scoop that he was going to
give us the actual stuff that i joined
on
yeah so i'm sorry if i told you guys
because that's that's what we
had but i guess you know legal issues
but you'll probably know the next couple
of hours
however the number it's a number that
might surprise you
i'm looking forward to that yeah yeah
listen there's a little inside baseball
and i can't tell you because i don't
want to be subpoenaed on that
though you know on the big tech issue
god i hope i never get dragged in
but it was it was a bigger number than
we thought on the amiky thing 18
18 17 yeah that's uh
that's surprising and you know if just a
few of them actually sack up to uh to
actually you know
yeah have some skin in the game that
could be a big deal uh did i make his
did i make his audio better for you
so good okay so uh by the way hit the
notification bell if you are subscribed
because
uh uh subscriptions don't mean a whole
lot and let me know by the way comment
if you got a notification yesterday
because a lot of people didn't get a
notification or only got it
after the stream had been off air for an
hour so yeah
that's another example of youtube
screwery which we will get into
in uh a little bit um we have a bunch of
news to get to also their hearings right
now going on
in georgia which we'll be covering in a
little bit uh but first
we talked about eric swalwell yesterday
but you know yesterday you weren't here
with us no no no no no but i'm following
banging fang
you know you're people pronouncing it
i love you my fang fang you don't know
wang the spy not indonesian
no okay we can bring that up whatsoever
um so eric swallow we covered this
yesterday
and we so boldly uh assumed that he did
it
yeah yeah yeah um and
he just released a state i think we have
a clip now in response to it first what
he said
and what he should have continued saying
was nothing
wisdom there dead he responded see if
you
hear uh not guilty in there this is
swallow's response
but the wrong doing here jim is that at
the same time this story was being
leaked out
is the time that i was working on
impeachment on the house intelligence
and judiciary committees
and if this is a country where oh people
who prisonerize the president are going
to have law enforcement
information weaponized against them
that's not a country that any of us want
to live in and i i hope it is
investigated as to
who leaked this information
if i if i'm cr if i'm crossing if i'm
pretty sure i just go
what'd you do you mean the fbi sex
tape yeah you mean
and i understand by the way using arms
of the government like the fba value the
cia
uh or the internal revenue service to
target political opponents i understand
that's a problem obviously i would agree
with you on that but more pressing
did you bang an asian spy on tape
right and by the way the surest way to
derail impeachment was to go after
swalwell
like he wasn't in charge of it he was
working with other people at
that point just lie like you you clearly
the chinese spy has no
problem lying right yeah yeah sleeping
their way to the top of swalwall
once the story is released just you know
just say it was obama at that point if
you're never probably
lying yeah yeah somebody's
going over here you're saying he should
have said he was sleeping with obama or
no no no no
like once the chinese spy probably
didn't really know you know cultural
differences and then came back it was
like you know
like a like a like a dog bringing in a
dead bird i think they brought you a
gift you're like i don't want that like
hey
and they're like oh it's slow wow son of
a [ __ ]
yeah you're fired really it was like
sleeping your way to mediocrity not the
top
right so she really she was like the sea
team and they were like yeah yeah yeah
just see if you can find just some
random
there's training no it was swalwell
being like i'm really important
oh please tell me you double bag it
bagging
also this is something interesting
andrew clavin has talked about this if
there's a scandal with a republican or a
conservative
it's it's about that scandal right and
if it's a scandal with
a liberal like swell it's how did they
get the information
same thing happened by the way with that
man andrew breitbart with anthony weiner
where he had pictures of his
giant throbbing erection wieners from
the
space odyssey angle
[Music]
and they just claimed that nothing was
going on and then they said well how did
andrew breitbart procure this and that
was andrew breitbart's are you saying
well that's my question is who else has
these pictures and what kind of leverage
do they have in our officials just
prosciutto jimber shootout cnn just
did you have sex with the asian spy
and was she worth it that's that's the
question i'm sorry was that a yes you
slept with a spy
or a no she walked out when you dropped
your baby can you imagine
can you imagine if there were i don't
know let's say actual videographic
evidence of donald trump
washing watching russian prostitutes
peeing on furniture
that would be the story for the entire
day i've been watching seen in a 24 hour
cycle
they barely touch it and then they ask
them that and they go well
what happened i can't believe that this
information was leaked good enough for
me
back to you papi well we don't have to
imagine stephen his taxes were leaked
illegally and then covered
in contravention to all of the youtube
facebook twitter's
policies on in hacked information being
linked and it was put out there nobody
asked
for that well no no trump we don't have
to imagine if something could happen
like that for trump yeah right we have a
specific case oh speaking of which we
have more info on hunter biden turns out
oh
no certified oh no he is under
investigation
it's a tax issue that's some people say
look it's a tax issue a tax issue in
relation to
china going on right yeah corruption
with china
um a lot of chance sorry half fashion
you know
a lot of the child a lot of the chinese
stories today look look look i'm just
gonna say that the chinese you know
version of the kgb
cia's right now killing people's
families for having been caught i mean
the
the person who slept with swalwell like
her whole line is gonna be wiped out
for having gone over someone solo
they're very ruthless
what can i say man you know you think
she'll be punished for
it not being someone higher up yeah
they're gonna make her go back and do it
again with swalwell
no no go until he's important go until
he's important
oh no that's actually that's what he
said to her that's what he screams
with prosciutto and cheese i am relevant
um they let her live for better than
this come on
as a baby come on oh hey by the way uh
we don't know how long we'll be on here
so uh we are on parlor
uh facebook things are changing a little
bit and um we'll be taking some live
chat as we cover these hearings in a
little bit on georgia
um for mug club only livecutter.com mug
club that's what allows us to do this
and that's what allows us to do
the live stream next week still uh you
know 10 a.m
eastern from nevada we will be driving
around we're creating the maps
if i could go to hundreds or thousands
of addresses i would i think we'll
probably be able to hit somewhere
between
20 and 40. it'll be between three and
six hours of streaming
and you can see that these addresses
don't exist
nothing to see there i i double dog dare
you to ban this youtube um
oh another story before we move on
because we have a lot to talk about with
youtube so much i'm glad my half an
asian kraken's here um
you guys probably know that um that
michigan representative um
rupaul cynthia johnson that'll make
sense in a second
um threatened trump supporters on
facebook and she's actually been removed
from her post so many of you
have seen this probably uh but
i watched it and i was appalled and
sometimes what happens with the show is
i'll watch something i'll see it
breaking i'm appalled and then by the
time i have to cover it on the show i've
seen it two three times
and some of that that fire is gone yeah
so um
actually this is what we will introduce
as a new segment so you know exactly how
he's feeling at that moment in time so
you know that i'm in this fight with you
where we will watch this tape and i will
get into the zone in what we call
reacting
okay uh so let me get in the head space
of when i saw this yesterday maybe it
was the day before
um so you can know exactly how i was
feeling
um at that point in time let's go to
michigan democrat
state representative cynthia rupaul
johnson
so this is just a warning to you
trumpers
be careful walk lightly
we ain't playing with you enough
of the shenanigans
enough is enough
and for those of you who are soldiers
you know how to do it do it right
be in order make them pay
i love you all bye-bye
[Music]
it's like you were there yeah wow oh man
wow how do you that was riveting you're
amazing did you
did you have to like go under your past
to like use something i wrote a book
from daniel day lewis
but then i just kept running around the
house going leave me my name
yeah i've abandoned my boy
you're digging through the fridge
looking for a milkshake i drink your
milkshake
i drink it up what is this what is this
that's when joe lewis goes hides behind
the couch he's like not the milkshake
i don't want him to take my milkshake um
all right so we just went through that
my question to you by the way as we go
into youtube again just comment below
this is the best thing you can do to
help these uh get through the youtube
algorithm
um have you seen can you remember any
example
while we're talking about youtube and
their interference now in not only
pre-election but
post-election news coverage uh can you
think of anything comparable
happening happening with someone from
the left and i don't mean a
leftist channel being taken down for a
copyright strike it take you know i mean
actually like removing
fake news from the left for example like
russia or
peeing russian prostitutes tell me if
anything comes to mind
uh i remember i remember a really good
one it was back at the beginning of it
when
all these sites were like don't wear
masks terrible and you remember youtube
came by and they just removed
all of those yeah oh no they didn't know
well we but no but we
were uh fact checked we got because we
said you know wearing masks is good
yeah yeah commie yeah and then and
youtube said see fouchy
and he was like don't wear masks and i'm
like oh my gosh
you can never we can never put one over
on fouchy
it's tough to do that when someone has
no accountability or track record of
being right
um just just google for people out there
vouchy aids just run a quick look in the
history fouchy aids
yeah okay so i don't know if google will
tell them but yeah i don't know if
google's somebody else
go put safe search on uh so here's
youtube
we'll recap what kind of happened
yesterday i want to go through this with
my half fashion layer builders and
youtube claimed
uh um about the election you know
stories we will start removing
any piece of content uploaded today or
any time
after that misleads people can you bring
this up there as an overlay
that misleads people by alleging that
widespread fraud or
errors changed the outcome of the 2020
presidential election
in line with our approach towards
historical
u.s presidential elections um
i guess we don't have the policy up here
as noble you guys saw it yesterday yeah
uh do we do we have it there audio pull
it up okay just know that i'm not lying
just go to google
or youtube and type in policy now if
you're looking for it it's under the
heading of spam
and scams yes exactly or by the way just
hit loader
uh there's a link in the description
below and we have all the links and the
sources that we try to make available to
you
so uh damon scam sounds like a buddy cop
movie
and scam could you clean up your room oh
you're
so uptight it's like fake ham and the
other fake ham
and scampi i mean it is like a buddy cop
animal movie
you know where it's like a cat and a
they talk yeah hedgehog or something
um but nobody you just like a buddy cop
film with youtube and facebook
right where all they do is beat down
black eyes mercilessly with no cause
while they tackle on their billions of
dollars so a quick by the way a quick
youtube search reveals
it shows us that this is not true to be
clear so i want to read this quote again
um that they will remove any piece of
content uploaded today or after
that misleads people by alleging that
widespread fraud or
errors change the outcome of the now the
key there is they say 2020 election
yeah because why does it apply to other
elections in other words the spirit of
the law
should be okay you want to remove
fraudulent information
um well as of right now i think we have
a montage there are still
many clips uh up claiming that the 2016
win
of president trump your president not
president-elect because jim prosciutto
says so
uh lost uh because of fraud in 2016.
russia hacked the 2016 elections and
they're going to do it again
it's not that the russians will be back
still up they haven't left
and they will only get better their
methods will only grow more
sophisticated
u.s officials say that they have no
reason to believe the russian cyber
attacks will
stop elaine the other problem is it is
likely that the russian hacking units
hit targets that have yet to
show up on us investigators radar you
can get a hashtag trending on twitter
or chum the waters with fake news
directed to audiences primed to receive
it or drive
journalists to dissect terabytes of
email for a cent of impropriety
all tactics used in russian operations
then you've got a shot
effectively camouflaging your operations
in the mind of your target
if this were red dawn they'd be fighting
against the wolverines
well i hear swayze they themselves in
perpetuating this narrative have been
doing the bidding for
not really so much the russians but the
chinese oh absolutely
that's also how swalwell fell into the
trap i appreciate that
it is it is so so that by the way so
they can push this which is verifiably
false
there has been an investigation unlike
right now where there have been suits
filed and there hasn't been
a full investigation right uh there has
the suits aren't even done
the election the disputes have not even
been resolved
that is resolved it did not happen
donald trump
basically was a he was a victim of the
greatest witch hunt of modern american
history
for a phone call you may not like it
but and bill barr had to say and you
know he probably really didn't want to
um something else while we're talking
about this
sure they still have in disinformation
up there about the russian hacking
but youtube while they're saying right
now they're going to get rid of anyone
who even addresses widespread voter
fraud
they still have content up on their
platform
that is bordering on some of it no is
outright illegal here you go
what you do is you light it and you keep
the
flame about an inch away now if you see
what i'm doing you slowly rotate it
left and right and then you'll start to
see a vapor start to come up and then
you hit it keep it lit and hit it and
keep rotating it you got some hairs
got some molly how to sell it
what a title is it i mean private or are
they doing this they're shipping their
shipping
we use all three providers actually he
went on shark tank
whatever it takes to get in here how to
sell drugs
on youtube they're not stupid either
they know what's going on everybody's
doing right now
so i'm gonna try and order some drugs
online and to do this i'm gonna set up
my own instagram account and snapchat
account
animal cruelty
[Music]
we'll we'll try and keep this as short
as possible
that's the one that i guess youtube
might say is borderline content
no that's a copyright strike from
netflix on cuties yeah it's a
copyrighted cruise let's turn because
you have little girls and thongs
apparently that's not a problem and and
uh it is and we blurred it so it's like
it wasn't blurred originally no
but but we didn't blur the drug dealer
guy no that's the thing all right
exactly though we knew who it was when
that same face and blur showed up at
chart on shark tank saying
i'm seeking 20 million dollars for a 10
stake in my crack house
in what do you think maybe not
like all right uh oh i don't i know
laura grenier might be right for this
because you sell cheap [ __ ] on qvc
um anything and and by the way youtube
isn't i wanna we'll open up the floor to
bill richmond and stuff and everyone can
let us know what's going on with the
georgia hearings youtube's not only let
these videos obviously flourish
regarding the 2016 myths
but they also have allowed many videos
that just claim donald trump is an
illegitimate president
right you can still find these things
right now available
on youtube um and and the funny thing is
too
they're they're fact checks about the
election they just redirect to a general
government website that says
oh no the election's been called or any
claims of voter fraud are in dispute
that's all that's all there's no link to
ongoing lawsuits there's no link to
evidence there's no link to voter rolls
there's no link to the complaints to the
file
there's no link right now to the supreme
court case you may not like it
but that is relevant and these disputes
are still
ongoing well and i know that there's
this fraud kind of thing that they put
in there but why did they
use the word errors if you refer to
election errors like the only way we're
going to do that is if there
was an error made like it's a binary
thing they either did it right or they
didn't do it right
why would you give them a caveat and the
other part of that is the the phrase
widespread right right
no one's alleging that you know there
was some like elections hold on one
second
giuliani is on he looks pretty good for
a guy with a disease with a 99.97
georgia stands out in a way
and will always stand out in posterity
with regard to this election because you
you have the
you you you have the thing that's going
to live after this election no matter
what
and that is the videotape that proves
that anyone who says that fraud is um is
uh
been debunked or there is no fraud is
just plain blind or lying
you have uh live from atlanta
you've got voter fraud right in front of
people's eyes
it's tough to tell the difference
between uh kovid rudy and non-covid rudy
yeah
yeah debilitating disease but that's
just the way he is
you know it seems like he's doing okay
seems like he's quarantining but i
thought he would be
wheezy yeah i think he stared covered in
the eyes and goes you can't take me
lower than i already
am right yes yeah yeah yeah sorry dude
you know what you're right
i had him i i forced a meeting of the
five coveted families
and used rico
by the way uh well because we have some
personal info as well on youtube that
we've experienced but youtube
said they're looking even in further
ways to decrease uh anyone who
contradicts the election narrative
here's another quote
despite these encouraging results we
recognize there's always more to do
for example while problematic
misinformation represents a fraction of
one percent of what's watched on youtube
in the united states we know we can
bring that number down even more
and some videos while not recommended
prominently on youtube and yours truly
continue to get high views sometimes
coming from other sites
we're continuing to consider this and
other new challenges
as we make ongoing improvements um
one quick thing too tim poole uh
reported that youtube
clarified to him so i don't know if i
can necessarily uh if i can
confirm this sure um and have we heard
any answer from youtube at all
we haven't had a comment yet okay we
haven't had a comment yeah well that's
always
heartening um it seems to be the common
response the two conditions that must be
met according to tim poole is a video to
be removed is they must claim
widespread fraud and error and say that
it made trump lose so you can still say
there's evidence maybe of fraud
and you can still say that trump
actually won but you cannot combine the
two and here's what's crazy
talk about controlled opposition i'm not
talking about some deep state mind
control
technique but when you say okay hey
listen you can say that donald trump
you think donald trump won okay uh but
you just can't substantiate it
the opinion is i think this election was
unfair right or i don't think
biden won anyway uh they go okay well
what makes you think that
well i can't tell you that why because
you're a stranger
if someone says i think donald trump won
because there are these thousands of
votes from
uh from addresses that don't exist
thousands of votes from people out of
state
thousands of votes from people under age
their algorithmic statistical improv
banned so what do you end up with
youtube ends up with liberals nbc
abc cbs universal vox disney
write all of these turner and then the
conservative on there who just goes well
i don't care what
i don't care what anybody says i think
trump won they go see
see that's all conservatives have
because someone like us saying well this
is why i actually think it was an unfair
election and we point to the actual
irregularities and the court briefings
get banned isn't that brilliant the way
the way they've
kind of threaded the needle here to make
it impossible to give
a truly credible argument at this point
going forward right right
is they've said you can either say trump
won
but don't give the substantiating
evidence to which then anyone can go
if they had evidence they would have
said it exactly and then or you can just
say without saying what the conclusion
is give the evidence right which is to
say
oh these elections like this number of
votes was wrong
this number of votes were you know
incorrect ballots shouldn't be counted
uh came in after a deadline etc but you
can't then tie it to the conclusion
which is
it's impacted the outcome of the
election right so now you can just give
this
but it's irrelevant there's no context
okay so five thousand ballots
what do you mean well i can't tell you
what i mean by that right i can't tell
you how it gets
the role i can't tell you why it's
relevant youtube is trying to cultivate
an environment where you can voice
an opinion and not substantiate it
what's being banned from youtube right
now what causes a problem
is statistical factual legal
substantiation
you can say i think donald trump won or
i think the election's unfair
you just can't provide the sources and
evidence
which is great that makes perfect sense
because the people who've you know
housed in youtube studios the young
turks are playing
like nbc vox where they co-produce shows
with them they don't provide sources so
wonderful for them
they they stand no risk to run afoul of
something that limits transparency but
these are strange times that we live in
so we cannot talk about widespread voter
fraud
if we were to insinuate that that may
have impacted the election however from
what i understand
and i don't understand much get there
youtube
can't stop us from thinking
about widespread voter fraud which may
have led to donald trump winning the
election so
um i'd like to take a moment and
exercise that remaining right
[Music]
all right
so we still have that going for us yeah
are we still are we still up i don't
know if we're still still
that felt good you sure i like that some
minority report spiders are gonna crawl
in here in a second
i didn't even have to have the tin foil
this time um what were you about to say
something earlier sorry i know to cut
you off for crazy rudy uh no
so and i love rudy giuliani but he's a
little he's you know that's what makes
him fun
so what's interesting is now you're
starting to see more of kind of the true
to true colors right right so you've
always said right like hey you're a
business you know in the same way that
you can decide who comes in your
business that kind of thing you just
have to be open about it
and you can't violate certain laws as
they're related to who you're letting
your business
and so with youtube now they're you're
starting to see the true colors what's
interesting is
you aren't seeing those same true colors
when it comes comes to facebook and the
stuff that they just
randomly take off throttle you know
remove that kind of thing do we have an
answer yet from facebook and why
the biggest independent election stream
was taken down no
they they haven't even answered no no
and you let them know that you're a
lawyer
correct i did i did i said i was like
look
i'm a lawyer i don't know where my law
degree is so i didn't send it to them
right
yeah i will find it under you know in my
mom's closet and
take a photo and send it to your honor
motion to dismiss
why we don't really give a [ __ ] it's a
motion
to confirm no shit's given yes exactly
right no answer we're just taking down
an election night from facebook
none whatsoever think about that for a
second yeah
fans millions of followers on facebook
and we've spent a substantial
uh substantial amount of money
advertising on facebook we don't anymore
of course
because they courted me reached out and
said hey you want to spend money to grow
your business on facebook
and then they ban the election stream
and don't even answer not only through
the channels available
the email the contact forms but an
actual
notice from a lawyer a reach out they
don't answer
how do you run a business how do you run
a business imagine that imagine that's
like wait hold on a second
you were gonna build my house there's no
house
you send an email hey where's my house i
paid for a house
and then you make a phone call i paid
for it and then you have a lawyer saying
hey we're gonna have a problem what
happened to the house
just radio silence must be nice to be
worth 700 billion dollars
right well and i watched an entire cnn
segment this morning that was supposed
to be covering this they had two
correspondents in there to talk about
i'm like oh a little bit of back and
forth that'll be fantastic
all they said i swear to you you can go
back and watch this all they said is
that
there was nothing there they didn't
mention the statements that were made in
the suit that
general paxton brought they didn't say
any of the other states that came on no
they just said of course
they didn't like the election results
and that was what they i was like
this is your like billions of dollars
budget to go out and produce something
like that
i don't i don't like the youtube search
results well i know where's my
restitution
i don't know where's my 40 acres and a
digital mule emoji yes
i mean there's no there's no question
here and when you look at all the
anti-truths there are many questions
but there is of all the questions a
question that is totally answered
already is
are all of these different companies at
some level you know working together
to make sure that there's a consistent
lid for using joe biden's words a
consistent lid
on any questions or dissent going
forward about where this is
i mean this is what's crazy and this is
why america is so great is even though
these companies are coming in
and feel that they can suppress any
discussion about this going forward
at least we still have a legal system
that allows us to file these briefs but
as general paxton said
this is the this is the last resort
right original jurisdiction in the u.s
supreme court
to settle the dispute that invalidates
or reduces the impact of americans votes
in all states
and this is it this is the last one
because it will be erased
from the internet yeah afterwards and
i'm really tired i will say this i'm
really tired of the republicans out
there grand sending on 2 30 not really
doing a whole lot listen guys let me
tell you
i may have a major announcement here to
make next week uh
there's no cap there's no cavalry come
over the hill okay
not to be unless it's people like us but
the people who are perpetually employed
and even if they're republicans who
fancy themselves bulldogs
there's some information out there that
we know has been presented to people who
could do something about it and they
don't want to stick their neck out so
there's a problem with that too and we
need to vote them out
um and we'll cross our t's and daughters
but actually i have someone here that's
a slight disagreement with my lawyer and
because it's a yeah agreement he's gonna
kick my ass okay so
uh comment if you're watching just hit
like comment right now it's the best
thing you can do if you're a freeloader
and you won't join mug club
which may be our only place not too long
from now all right
you know i've run into this quite a bit
while you're talking about sort of the
legal recourse
right that's also something that youtube
when we're talking about 230.
they don't uh they don't even follow and
i know what you were saying about let me
explain this first then you make your
argument and then i would like to i
think you're but we're about to agree
okay oh no um youtube enjoys protection
but they don't even follow
laws as it relates to states they don't
even follow state laws
meaning single party dual party consent
states
meaning that if you videotape someone
you record somebody in a single party
consent state
you don't need their permission that's
how investigative journalism is done
right however youtube decides that they
don't
follow that so you just saw that right
there we've had videos removed
from people in single party consent
states by the way so we don't need to
ask for their permission
who gave permission on camera i think
actually
in one case written and then afterwards
so i don't like the way that it turned
out so i want it removed and they were
removed yeah
wow but that's not the state law and i
know you were saying there's something
they can go above and beyond the law on
that front well
so so the law itself says that here's
the threshold you're required if you
don't follow the law then you might have
that content removed so illegal content
that violates data sure
might be removed there's no obligation
that they allow us to do it to put it up
but here's the biggest problem is they
allow that content up
all the time they allow vice
vox cnn tmz they allow
all of this content up that is where the
person has affirmatively not consented
to be up there and they go well it's a
single party consent statement
right exactly sorry you got to let it up
but then when we do it
it's oh this random person who yelled in
public came into a place that clearly
they knew they were being done they
signed they agreed in the video they
were going to do it
but then later they realized they said
some stupid [ __ ]
and they complain to youtube and youtube
goes well i understand it's a single
party consensus but we need you to take
it down
right that is the hypocrisy that's
coming through on this particular issue
oh and also
i do think that it's a violation of law
overall because
if youtube is going to be a platform
right you don't get to stop someone in a
town square for example let's say you're
a police officer in a town square
and someone is videotaping people in
public and someone says i don't want to
be videotaped
all the police officers can do is say
well you get out of the town square so
if you are enjoying the platform of
being the digital town square which is
what you guys have claimed under 2
30 you do not get to say actually you
have to stop filming
especially not if we say hey we're
filming someone agrees to it or sits
down for example to change my mind where
they clearly know there's a camera and a
camera and a camera can on camera
and afterwards they say well we don't
want to do it
you take it down that's just let's recap
this really quickly youtube can create a
policy that says
we will remove any substantial claims
any substantiations
of the idea that donald trump lost if it
includes voter fraud right any claims of
voter fraud resulting in the outcome of
this election being
in dispute we will remove that's
something they will enforce
they do not enforce that when the left
says that the 2016
election was hacked by the russians and
that donald trump was illegitimate
then we moved down the list and it's hey
you know what we enjoy the protections
of 230 because we're a platform
we are not a publisher and then they say
but you have to take this down because
this person said they didn't want to be
filmed we don't care if it's a single
party consent state
that can remove all investigative
journalism from the right you've seen it
with us we've experienced it
you've seen it from people uh like james
o'keefe and then they say to vice
and these or vox these other outlets no
no but in your case as long as you're
following state law it's fine
it gives them the selective process to
determine
what information you can and cannot
see and that is what a publisher
does that needs to change
now it would be it's like it's almost as
bad as if youtube reached out to
creators and said like hey hey
uh before you submit anything let us
review it and give you some changes just
like an editor at the new york times
something like that the major the major
point here is when you look at 230 and
the protection that
incorrect court decisions have allowed
them to continue to do
is to translate 230s good faith
application of
removal policies and say that oh it's
okay for you to say you do it one way
with regard to single-party consent but
then do it a different way and the only
difference
is because of the types of content
that's being done the policies are
exactly the same
the ignoring or following a single
consent law by the creator is exactly
the same
but you let some people do it when
you're okay with the content and you
don't let them do it when it's other
creators with other content like your
stuff
and that's where you fall out of 230
that's where you violate what 230s you
should no longer have the protection
because you're no longer acting in good
faith to remove that this is just when
people get mad about the fact that uh
they decided to try and leak which is
illegal donald trump's tax returns
and then not cover hunter biden listen
that's you get mad at fox news cnn abc
nbc
great okay we understand and also on
twitter they allowed trump's tax returns
but they punted the hunter biden story
saying there was a violation of hacking
now take that
and apply it across anywhere anyone can
get information
and then these people at youtube and
facebook have the gall
to [ __ ] about echo chambers yes yes
you you're the chamber when i try to
when when
half asian bill reaches out to facebook
to say hey hold on a second
why did you ban our stream stream stream
stream it's just an echo
right well and this was this was our
protection right so this was the the
thing that we could go to to make sure
that our voice was heard we went to
these other platforms because we know
the media wasn't going to necessarily
cover all of the stories fairly
right this is how democracy this
democratic republic
dies it dies it dies here because if we
can't get
out factual information that maybe isn't
convenient for the people that own these
companies or maybe isn't convenient for
a political viewpoint
you can never have freedom of speech
again in this country you're just going
to believe whatever you're told
right and so for any of you out there
who are like why are you keep talking
about 2 30
because it is the very most important
thing going on
right now and if your representatives
don't take action getting
them out it's weird they don't have an
interest you know what sometimes when i
hear about this
there's some stuff i got no there's some
stuff i got to do it may mean that i
might not be able to do this show uh
in this capacity for much longer there's
some if no if other people aren't going
to step up there's some stuff i gotta do
so we'll have some announcements what's
that have patient bill
he can't announce he's just no i'm not
not saying anything i'm just saying i'm
just saying
don't be don't be surprised if if if i'm
not here doing
this show as you see it now because i'm
not going to be one of those guys who
you know you see these people in online
message boards and if we bleed together
we have brothers together what are you
doing
what are you doing now we've filed suits
in the passer file petitions of
information
but there's more that i can do i just
just can't do it and do this at the same
time so there are some decisions that
have to be made because yeah i'm not
gonna i'm not gonna see the thread
of our constitutional republic be be
tugged on and and have the opportunity
to do something and
and not do something about it and it
requires a little more than you know
whose whole
tingles it's zuckerberg with his little
alien finger
like mr burns in the cornfield with
nuclear radiation
um there's a great episode is there
something here that we want to watch is
that why this
uh it wasn't done this is a horrible
crime that's been committed against the
american people
georgia georgia has fact check they
weren't suitcases right
probably the piece of the most dramatic
evidence you don't have the most
cheating
you didn't have to cheat as much i mean
the margin was only ten thousand
the most cheating obviously occurred in
the places the margin was 12
000 pennsylvania which by the way it was
14 000 plus before a recount without
signature right
what's the level of [ __ ] i i i'm
guaranteeing that they're using this
the policy is directed specifically to
giuliani's stuff like
the new policy this is the kind of stuff
that they're going to be like oh
nope oh you're going to try and vanish
policy so big it's unclear
well then you know what you'll billable
hours bill
to come to the greatest nation on earth
because we let this happen
we let this erosion of our free speech
take place we let the erosion of our
freedom of religion let me ask you this
well we're talking about this right now
people out there
every there's back and forth you'll go
oh it's conjecture this is an election
of the most important
person in the free world yeah why do we
not have the ability
to simply check what votes went in at
that time in those machines
yeah constitutional relaxation of
ballot integrity protections right just
like hey well awesome
between uh what ten and one well we
weren't counting we were tabulating
okay what was tabulated yeah and the
answer on some of this stuff has been
like well
these are the sorts of machines that you
can't audit
what they gave us is it unreasonable for
me to say
okay how many went through with that
because it just happens to coincide with
the dump that flipped the state
yeah just those ones let's just look
look look at those votes
open it up go on through use a pen
i think
they don't have to show their work it's
the wizard of ballard we just take the
incompetence of the dmv and then you
transfer all those people over to the
state elections and
there you go they paid no attention to
the man in the ballot machine yeah
nothing could go wrong
they didn't debunk anything they just
said that they lied that was their claim
yeah they were like no no no no no one
uh actually no one was sent home and uh
uh yeah we said well hold on a second
you said people were sent home and you
stopped counting no no no no because
what we said was we said was um we sent
people home and we stopped counting
said the election official yeah exactly
now we have this video but what happened
is we didn't send anybody home
we didn't stop counting we just did it
yeah i was like you just got wapod facts
check it out i just proved my point
actually
oh look check i'm a liar if they're
about to show this video of this broad
with the absentee ballots it's like
giuliani has been watching
our show i feel like way when i watch
the news in one of these next hearings
it's just going to be our six
hour stream from next thursday we're
driving from non-voting address to
non-voting address and that's happening
what is next thursday what's the date
can someone let me know
thursday the 17th we'll have dave landau
some special guests
we are trying to set this up um now
listen the connection might drop so we
have to stream
here to this studio and if it drops
it'll just drop for maybe 30 seconds to
a minute stay with us
the reason for this is so many people
say well the numbers you don't really
know
we have done research and we don't have
enough time to show you
all of the [ __ ] addresses but we
will drive
that's the correct pronunciation
addresses uh but we will drive from
address to address to address to address
for as long as we have a tank of gas
and show you where the voter
registration
where people voted from which by the way
is illegal oh no no uh irregularities
right right right right maybe maybe
you gotta say uh non-widespread front
you can say like there was
yeah x tens of thousands right
there are many many tens of thousands uh
potentially hundreds of thousands of
this example of the kind of address
example that you can find
online but we don't have time
no we're still up because we'll be in an
rv not a delorean so
i don't know how many will be able to
show you but i just think it's important
that you see at least a couple dozen
right that way you know hey put a put
put a [ __ ]
[ __ ] address to the [ __ ] name that
they tell you doesn't exist
it exists some are empty lots some are
random boxes
some are just addresses on streets where
the numbers have already ended
really we've done our due diligence and
we will be driving from address to
address to address on thursday
we're taking a risk and we just want you
to go along with us our last
show of the year i don't expect it to be
on for a very long time
hey hey look when we we're out there i
mean you've made this point a number of
times which is hey guys if you're
sharing information you're welcome to
come back no no i'm sending my chinese
spies don't worry
you're you're closer to me that just
sounds like a party yeah
hey swallow will be there oh no nobody
doesn't share
but so look at it like we've talked
about this if you're sharing unvetted
information
as a conservative who is questioning
what's going on in this election
and you haven't vetted that information
like there's no doubt so well-meaning
people are sharing bad information
and that is creating a smoke screen that
allows the wapos to come in and go see
that one's bunk that one's the bunk that
one's the bunk that was bunk and it's
like okay fine
i didn't share those four these are the
ones that really matter and that's what
paxton was saying was look
some of that other stuff may or may not
be good it's not what we're doing but
what we're saying is
indisputable facts about how these
elections were run were run in violation
of their own laws
they set the rules they didn't follow
them and it led to a period a potential
impact on an election i haven't said
which election yeah no animal an
election somewhere
you never want to use the definitive
article the election we don't know what
happens
we don't know the inner workings of the
parliamentary system in botswana
we don't i i didn't whether this had an
impact son of a [ __ ]
uh ghana let's pick one that we don't
know they don't have a constitutional
system or a problem
no someone put me in a santa suit and
give me a kid to talk hey
um dude man can i go back to something
real quick you said something about this
but
at the end of that first quote where
they're saying that it impacted the 2020
us presidential election this is the
most
laughable this is this is what they said
oh nothing this is what they said this
is
i'm reading their policy right this is
the most laughable part
in line with our approach towards
historical us
presidential elections that last part
it is this policy has been historically
the same policy that you've had in
previously i know we covered talking
about 16
but i like how they threw that in there
right there on the thing didn't even
have to say that
and said it's just the same that we've
been doing before
youtube's been around since 2005. yeah
yeah
we're not not bush i guess the end of
his deal obama you did this for that
romney yeah he did it for that too right
well i mean those people were wieners
and inconsequential so
they weren't really willing to fight
they didn't really need to they didn't
really need to
try and beat the fight out of romney or
mccain no they just folded it certainly
not romney
yeah they just placed him on the top of
their car like he did their dogs
they grabbed his ponytail exactly they
grabbed mitt romney's ponytail
they hit him hard they just dragged
romney's ponytail and like
just a little speed bag like come on
romney come on he's like all right i'm a
democrat
yeah holy underwear wedgie no i know i
think
i think underwear doesn't wedge oh
that's true it's very
we speak of holy things speaking of
unbelievable
hunter biden hey by the way many people
may not remember this uh
ten percent of americans said it would
have changed their vote had they heard
about the hunter biden story i don't
know if you can bring that up there
uh uh at some point have someone send it
there to token owen
because i do have some other overlays
here but um hunter biden now is the
subject of a federal tax investigation
yes
yeah it just happened right this is
confirmed of course this is breaking
news
that was reported in october
wait maybe this is maybe there's maybe
this is the component that tucker
carlson
lost in the mail
i remember back you remember that way
back in the october days
yeah we were like why isn't this what
bigger story right
this is what yeah it was taking off
twitter wait it was taking off twitter
taking off
he was so strung out on crack and foot
jobs
that he left his computer with geek
squad there was nothing illegal
not his phone he didn't even wake up he
didn't even wake up he left that there
was i think the rule was at 60 days or
90 days whatever it was it was past
that rule he didn't even come back after
a 90-day
crack and foot job stupor and go hey i
didn't leave my incredibly incriminating
laptop here did i
he didn't even that have that awareness
but jack dorsey well flan decided that
they were going to remove
the hunter biden story and they were the
ones stupid enough to outright remove it
yeah it looks like the number was one in
six biden voters would have changed
their minds if they had known the full
story
one in six bite voters would have
changed their population to me
what's the margin in swing states so
let's even let's not even talk about the
change the election widespread fraud
which of course
never happened and this hearing isn't
going on and we didn't just have the
texas a g right none of that figment of
your imagination
nothingness i'm thinking about it it
doesn't matter
stop it thinking about it
it is not a fair election because
of the fact that the media controls all
this information yeah if you take away
the fact that they completely suppressed
the biden story that they'd amplified
the russia story that they had amplified
the impeachment story that they'd
amplified
uh donald trump's tax returns let me ask
you this how many times did you hear in
the mainstream media that we had
unemployment
at 3.6 percent
when did you ever hear that ever when
did you ever hear that more americans
had dollars in their pockets
both in their paycheck and saving from
their paycheck paying in taxes
when did you ever hear about that when
did you ever hear in the media that the
average
family household income went up 5 000
under donald trump where it was 1 000
under the entirety
of obama's administration when did you
ever hear that
none of it you heard none of that
information it wasn't a fair election
because these big tech billionaire
oligarchies effectively decided that it
could not be
and by the way while we're talking about
this i do think that businesses
have the right to make political
donations when you're talking about
citizens united
again you don't know about that case
what that was was hillary clinton
actually trying to ban
an anti-hillary clinton film but
democrats talk about how they're against
big money and politics how about the 350
million from one guy
zuckerberg to get out the vote campaigns
seems like a lot you don't have a
problem with that so let's not act like
this is a fair election regardless
of the hundreds of thousands of voters
that either don't exist or out-of-state
underage or double-voted illegally voted
so so one thing
i'll say this may be a controversial
opinion um there is a distinction
between
influencing rigging and fraud right and
i would say
that to us to at a certain level there
could even be violations of campaign
finance laws
through supporting a particular
candidate or belief or set of systems or
a party
through your actions that may not be
fraud because fraud is lying or not
lying so what
what's interesting about the hunter
biden thing is the timing of going
through and saying
we're not going to let this information
out right that may not be fraud under a
legal standard
but without question it was influence
without question it was trying to rig
the election
so that information was not getting out
that clearly
citizens would have been using and that
was demonstrable at the time true
under an argument that we don't let this
kind of information out because it was
found
surreptitiously right when you let that
information out
all the time right on other topics
that's where
where the phrase fake news comes from is
where the left was saying that
all of these facebook like the headlines
were deceiving and right that was the
reason that trump was
elected but they they can point out the
media
influence and they can also point out
some kind of fraud that happened might
have happened in 2016 but
we can't hey by the way really quickly
can you bring back up that swalwell clip
yeah let's bring that back up because
you know swalwell who was banging asian
spies um
certainly confirmed the problem you
can't tell whether it's the same one or
multiple because they're
always switching out he's also just he's
just
in a pool of asian spies
like uh gary oldman in the awful
rendition of dracula so
it's just eric's oh well and pointy tits
um that was weird let's play the
squallwell clip because there's
something in there that he said that i
think might be relevant to the hunter
biden
scenario play it but the wrong doing
here jim is that
at the same time this story was being
leaked out is the time that i was
working on impeachment on the house
intelligence and judiciary committees
and if this is a country where people
who criticize the president are going to
have law enforcement
information weaponized against them
that's not a country that any of us want
to live in and i hope
it is investigated as to who leaked this
information so his problem was with
selective leaking
right well we know that intelligence
agencies i don't know maybe token now
can grab this i don't know if it was the
cia or fbi
or the internal revenue service had
hunter biden's laptop while the story
was being covered in october
fbi it was the fbi i believe is the fbi
the fbi had the laptop
hmm and decided to hold on to that until
after the election
where's swalwell on that i know you have
a problem when someone's leaking you're
leaking on an
asian spy prostitute but where are you
when it comes to drip drip you know but
buttoning this up
and fixing the leak in the pipe so that
nobody knows and people are made to feel
crazy if they say this hunter biden
story is really important because it
could compromise
the next leader of the free world they
had access to it all this time yeah
yeah how about the selective leaking
outrage there
you're a conspiracy theorist yeah pretty
much and it's not like so cnn i was
telling you i mean
you understand the point that i'm making
yeah yeah yeah that's what i was saying
oh the real problem
isn't it suspect that they're leaking
this now i would argue
sure but
you did have sex with asian spies yeah
you know those things you can literally
deal with both of those you can deal
with both of those you can say
hey wait a minute we need to figure out
how these investigations are being
compromised and how it's being released
that doesn't change you you didn't
unbang the bell
i mean right unbanged the fang you
didn't do it
well look i had to watch that hold on a
second general rule of thumb just
don't have sex with any chinese women
anymore hey they're not really that into
you
no i wouldn't even be here chinese men
are fine stephen we have it the wrong
way he actually recruited her
he was right please involve me in a
scandal so that i'll be on the news
again yeah i need to be relevant i want
people to care so
he told her he was president-elect
because that's
the other office of president-elect well
it gets even worse so cnn not only did
they say that this is breaking news i
watched a segment this morning on this
as well they had the
balls to say it was because of the
intrepid reporting of blah blah our
reporter and people shaking their heads
yes did a fantastic job uncovering this
so what did you do go back and watch our
clips from october to get your
information because this is not only not
breaking you didn't do a damn thing to
get the information care at all
i bet you know that if they've come out
and said he's under investigation
now um it must be really bad yeah
because just what we have
is really bad uh and what's funny is
uh uh um former vice president joe biden
uh released a statement
that's right saying that he was deeply
proud
of his son that was really his only
commentary
and you know what listen we can see why
yeah he has every reason to be
yeah proud i believe yeah you know
so many things yeah man yeah that's it
just
man i hope i can raise a son and they're
gonna get him on his taxes
amazing look hunter you're in the news
it's like it's like al capone if al
capone were the former vice president's
[ __ ] son
[Laughter]
can you just i just can't wait when we
see him designing the new uh
what is it he's gonna go out to the rose
garden you know it's gonna be hunter
biting in and you're like why are all
these
roses white why are they so powdery
that's weird that's weird
that's strange man hey what are these
these are these poppies
these aren't poppies so hey hey bill
there's just a question
so taxes right uh regarding
his taxes regarding his influence his
business dealings where
it's not you know it's not clear uh it's
either vermont or china
oh oh it could be china vermont i mean
like there's a place called
egypt uh texas yeah yeah yeah mexico
missouri so the the places that biden is
going to be tougher on than donald
trump yeah or where yeah so i'm just
making sure i can connect all
it'll work out we're crying out loud the
bibs were having
cocktail parties with swall wells they
were probably handing out numbers for
their masseuses
do people you really think that it's
that hard to connect the dots do you
think i'm some serial killer with yarn
hold on a second no wait we really only
need three points of contact
hunter biden crack cocaine foot jobs
from chinese hookers
and chinese business dealings eric slow
well banging chinese spies
joe biden there you go there you go
connected the dots it's like a
children's menu at denny's
yeah there's gonna be the next policy
that comes out that's like under the
spamming scam
right it's gonna be like yeah it would
the the the integrity of the first son
needs to be respected yeah
he needs his space to sew his wild crack
and that was even easier than the six
degrees of kevin bacon so that was nice
i like it let's go really quickly to the
georgia hearing and by the way the best
thing you guys can do if you're watching
right now the archive just comment
something we're doing an ask me anything
next thursday where we will be streaming
live december 17th
all of these addresses and we'll be
taking your questions in your chat so
load them up and uh no question is too
uncomfortable though i don't promise
i'll answer way back
into uh counties in kentucky or in your
case georgia
all right that's enough about that part
of it
it's important to understand at a very
high level sort of how the dominion
system works
it really can you explain it in a way
that resembles blood
i'm going to call them i'm already on it
and the adjudication
i have been told that my voice is quite
similar in frequency to that of
it's not even watching paint dry the
paint's already dry now it's just paint
eroded
right i think what he's saying is that
the computers were connected to the
internet so that was the biggest thing
yeah
and this is the problem to us why we
wanted to have ken paxton on the show
sorry attorney
general ken pax on the show to try and
boil this down listen i will tell you
this there are too many sparks in the
conservative movement as you see right
there not enough kirks it's great to
have information that information needs
to get to people
who can distill it communicate it
delegate it and
fight with it and i tell you what we see
a lot of people presenting information
we don't see a lot of people out there
certainly with our elected officials
uh fighting with that information
fighting the information war actually
going to war for the american people who
elected them we do not see
that enough and you know how that's do
you know how you can
confirm that's true you're shocked when
you see it
the fact that everyone is going lion ted
lion he went from lying ted
according to me to lion ted because he's
willing to go forward and argue at the
supreme court
that shouldn't be an event that should
be the rule
not the exception and we have seen time
after time people sit on the sidelines
who were not
brought into office to sit on the
sidelines and then they [ __ ]
about donald trump and how he's a bull
in a china shop well you know what
maybe he wouldn't have to be a bull in a
china shop if some of you guys just went
in there and bought some [ __ ]
took some stuff off the shelves every
now and then we shouldn't need
one guy we shouldn't hope for and i
don't believe that he's one guy i don't
believe that there's any savior to the
political party but i
am at the point right now where if the
republicans who we've elected
conservatives who we've elected haven't
done enough
if they sit on the sidelines go here's
some information that maybe you might
want to look into
hey how about you look into it how about
you do your due diligence so that i
don't have to work 15 hours a day
actually confirming it
and then you go forward and fight
because you have the legal standing to
do so
how about you stop being [ __ ] because
guess what you don't deserve
any of our votes whoa really you just
you you just think uh are you gonna no
i'm not gonna vote for a democrat that's
not what i'm saying
well what about the con what about the
future of the constitution what about
the future of the democracy guess what
you're not protecting it you're not
protecting it if you're not doing enough
at this point republicans out there
there are a lot of people myself
included out there going hey you know
what
what we've been doing isn't working they
don't seem to be not only do you not
seem to be fighting for us in the way
that you have been overwhelmingly
requested to
you don't seem like the kind of person
who would even understand the language
that we're all speaking here at a party
seems to me like you would be confused
if we bring up that georgia video or if
we bring up the voting rolls
if we bring up the idea of
unconstitutionality and uh legislating
from the bench in pennsylvania it seems
to me that a lot of these republican
representatives will be well i don't
know that's where the courses decide oh
i don't know i've seen a lot of
conspiracies
hey hey how about you take it upon
yourselves here since you have resources
for crying out loud endless resources
you're welcome tax dollars here's more
and start getting to the bottom of this
and at least using what we have publicly
available
to fight okay that's why we're here
right now and that's why we'll be here
as long as we can and i will do the show
as long as i can
until my role in fighting might have to
change because i am getting sick and
tired of folks who aren't doing anything
let not your heart be troubled and that
this country has some great safeguards
it really does and there's never the end
of the constitutional republic people
said that with bill clinton people said
that with barack obama
but we are at a tipping point in this
country and we are at a tipping point
where there isn't that cavalry coming
over the hill because
they don't care a lot of them not all of
them i'm not talking about people like
ted cruz i'm not talking about people
like ken paxton but how many other
republicans can you name
who are in the faces non-stop of the
people who you know are lying
and supporting big tech throttling and
censoring conservative voices
how how many how many did you see
signing on you had a new york ag who had
to file this suit
against facebook you guys have had four
years
what are you done now all of a sudden
we're gonna talk about uh 230 with the
uh what is the defense bill uh that that
donald trump is talking about
now all of a sudden when we're in a lame
duck presidency we're going to do
something
you had four years and it's all
people talked about and now you're
surprised
at what happened with the election
you're surprised that people are saying
there's no evidence you're surprised
that now youtube is saying
hey we've we've broken them up right so
now they'll all hang separately we've
broken them up so they're alone we've
instituted this mental warfare and told
them that there's no evidence
we can now just remove them from the
face
of the dialogue and it's because you
guys did
nothing and you know what at least i'm
gonna do what i can to try and
start holding you guys accountable and
that means both the left because we know
what our enemy is but like i talked
about this and when i say enemy i mean
political enemy ideological enemy don't
say i'm not like some michigan
representative
who looks like rupaul calling people
soldiers asking them to harm people who
disagree with me
i'm talking about an ideological enemy
at this point but that's not a tough
pill to swallow
like we talked about you know what it's
not tough for me to understand that some
hipster coffee shop in austin
is going to force everyone to wear masks
and walk around with ski poles to make
sure that they're six feet apart
what is a tough pill for me to swallow
is a church
saying well you know what we don't
really need to meet to be the
congregation of god
yeah you do you're just using your faith
as an excuse for your cowardice it's
it's it's the easier pill to swallow for
me to say well okay of course we see
elizabeth warren wanting people banned
who disagree with him well okay of
course we see people at dinner parties
with zuckerberg and wojjitsky and these
politicians who are
influencing our elections and banning
opinions we expect that it's like a
disobedient child
you expect them to be that way but when
you have the adults in the room
when you have republicans saying well we
need to just let the system play out
guess what the system plays out when you
play your role fix it
all right we're gonna go right now leave
a comment that's the best thing you can
do if you don't want to i understand
it burns to touch a keyboard but we do
ask that you join up at mug club there's
going to be quite a bit more show
where we will be taking your chats after
this
youtube go ahead and try and ban me why
don't you but right now piss off